good afternoon everybody i'm tom pollard
i'm the dean of the graduate school and
a professor of molecular science and
developmental biology and one of the
pleasures of this job is to pick out
interesting members of our faculty to
address the company of scholars lectures
and our lecture today is catherine katie
lofton
who i got to know when she was promoted
to associate professor last year that's
my talent scouting
activity sitting on all the promotions
committees
and she had such a striking uh
outstanding case i had to get to know
her better so i'm i've invited her to
give this talk
katie is an associate professor of
religious studies and of american
studies
she graduated from the university of
chicago with honors in both of those
fields
in 2000
and received her phd from the university
of north carolina in chapel hill in 2005
and then i don't know the story but she
wandered around a bit from reed to
indiana to princeton
uh before the short stints in each of
those in the desert just wandering the
desert wandering the desert before she
came to yale as an assistant professor
in
2009 and she was promoted last year to
associate professor in 2012.
so one of the things i learned about her
is that she's a fabulous teacher so i
knew she'd be great for this lecture the
story goes at least in her promotion
case was that she offered a a certain
course
that ballooned in its second year of
offering to be the biggest course in her
department overnight so she must have
done something right
her scholarship
is in the area of the history of
american religion and the theory of
religion and culture and along this line
she's written a
a book that's received quite a bit of
attention on oprah the gospel of an uh
of an icon
that's not what she's going to talk
about today she's going to be talking
about religion and the practice of
american parenting
and so we're looking forward to remarks
after her remarks we'll have a question
and answer period and then we'll have a
reception in the common room next door
katie
thank you so much tom um
you're like the william morris of yale
university right now i'm really honored
to get to do this and um
i'm going to talk today about a subject
that i've been working on for about a
year it's a project that's really
unfurling for me
and i really welcome in the q a
comments things that you free associate
this is the beginning to me of an
argument as my students know i have a
problem with speaking very very quickly
and so if i don't try to restrict myself
through the prose on the page you will
have a very hard time tracking my excess
so to that end i use the mechanism of
powerpoint as sort of a highlights reel
to accompany alongside my own excessive
verbosity
the subject i want to talk to you today
is is in some ways very much connected
to all the subjects that i mean these
are all subjects on which i have written
at some point or another and in some
ways there's this kind of excessive
multiplicity to the thing that i'm
venturing in
in this multiplicity
i am trying to name the religious now
i work simultaneously against the
secularization thesis and within it
as i am invested in the naming of
certain perpetual desires and social
forms as religious
while i'm also a scholar of what is not
perpetual
how americans are religious now is quite
different than they were in 1890 yet i
argue
we are all still religious
naming what remains and what has changed
is my work
so i am here to study what focuses our
existence
what defines our concept of the social
and what drives us to differentiating
rituals and identities this vocabulary
is i argue that of the study of religion
what makes the study of religion
somewhat different those since those
previous attributes could be assigned to
sociology or philosophy
but i argue what is different about
religion the study of it the practice of
it is the obsession with the other
religions describe and define
relationships established among groups
among individuals between self and
supernatural authority
religion names relationships between
self and gods i might say
rather than take up an exegesis today of
that particular term religion however
and i would say in the majority of my
scholarship my interest in less and
theorizing the object religion to begin
than to take another object
seemingly either far-flung or somewhat
proximate but different and look at that
so today the object i want to nominate
because i think it's usefully brought
into a conversation on the religious now
is parenting
the history of parenting is a relatively
recent history of inquiry
since parenting as a self-conscious
practice of cultivation is an artifact
of modernity
prior to the 20th century the verb to
parent appeared very rarely in the
english lexicon as a noun it referred
almost exclusively to a genealogical
description
before the 19th century few indications
of parenting as a practice of
cultivation exist was an exponential
increase in such usage after the 1920s
what i want to talk about is how this
shift took place under what terms
at the most generic level we could agree
that the parent is an emblem of
modernity and so far as parenting is a
matrix through which individuals reckon
with the concepts of individuality
social participation
and moral consciousness
despite the rich terrain for cultural
observation the parenting practices
offer parenting is a very strange lacuna
in humanist analysis
there is a scholarly literature about
published child care advice about the
changing role of the mother about the
social history of the family and the
cultural meaning of the child
yet there is very little about the
concepts of parental control or
practices of parenting
within u.s religious history scholars
have paid very little attention to the
religious dimensions of modern family
life despite the practical and
ideological connections between
religious ideation
and concepts of parental authority
in general there seems to be a sense
that religion particularly protestant
christianity in america
once played a very powerful job and role
in the work of parenting but that
religion largely disappeared from homes
in the clothes at the close of the
victorian era
according to the majority of historical
accounts religion within the family
like religion within the rest of
modernity disappeared in a presumptive
secularization
such a narrative depends on certain
sociologies of religion
including those that emphasize church
attendance or creedal adherence to prove
a declension
yet i want to reimagine today with you
the history of parenting as a document
of religion in a broader sense
one that emphasizes how parenting and
the formation of a family unit defined
by its practice
has increasingly become the definitive
religious focus of 20th and 21st century
americans
persistent throughout the documentary
evidence prescribing american parenting
practice is authority
descriptions of the authority of parents
and the meaning of that authority for
the propagation of the right society
to be sure romans and vikings parented
shakespeare's england had parents but in
the american context parenting becomes
an elaborate discursive regime a
sciencia parentis this is me that
propounded a potent identity for its
practitioners and a social politics for
everybody to debate
do in no small parts of the country's
colonial origins and its overthrow of
them
due in no small part to its relationship
to parents
parenting became a telling subject in
the new nation
as alexis de tocqueville observed of
america in 1840
when the social state becomes democratic
and men adopt as a general principle
that it is good and legitimate to judge
all things in relation to oneself
taking old beliefs as information and
not as rule the power of opinion that a
father exerts over his son diminishes as
does his legal power
the tophill here speaks about the
diminishing potency of the father in the
america elsewhere in his texas some of
you know he writes about america's
multiplying and tim quite strange
excessive religious communities
i link these two subjects fading forms
of patriarchy increasing forms of
religious creativity as bound together
unfettered from mother churches and
father lands america instantiated
parental authority in a prescriptive
excess
when authority is diffuse
even invisible it must be constructed to
exist
to observers of the nascent country
america was a vast frontier that lacked
the scaffolding of coherent authority
parenting and the literatures which
emphasized its importance offered maps
to this seemingly wrongly mapless
terrain
to be clear of course at any given time
parenting might be manifested in any
number of ways
at any given time few parents would hew
neatly to some prescriptive document
what i want to underline is not a
phenomenological truth but an
ontological one namely that parents
become the manifestation of authority
and recommendations about parenting were
recommendations about proper
self-governance within such an open
atmosphere
and as critics of religion and
psychologists of the family have
suggested the parental relation can
easily be figured analogously to the
religious relation
an indicative 1882 treatise on moral
education of children american
psychologist g stanley hall would write
in a much longer rhapsodic passage which
i here abbreviate the mother's face and
voice are the first conscious objects as
the infant soul unfolds and she soon
comes to stand in the very place of god
to her child
hall believed
that in infancy individuals developed a
relationship to their nurturing adults
akin to that of divine care
inferred from such an observation is an
ongoing corollary between the parental
relationship and subsequent divine
engagement in that infant's life
in the history of psychology the parent
often represents a divine proxy a just
parent like a just god would inspire
individuals to ascend beyond the
primitive projections of a retributive
authority
and instead pursue the good by their own
well-trained compass
all of this developmental theology
occurs around american cribs while
authority itself is declining as a
meaningful religious concept
here we see barbara defoe whitehead vice
president of the conservative institute
for american values who observed in 1995
there has been a debunking of leaders in
our society a turning away from clergy
and religious institutions
and while whitehead has a tendentious
view and unhappy view of this
epistemological observation i agree with
it sociologically and it seems right to
me to describe the relationship between
religious institutions and the religious
believer in america as a disobedient one
so much so that this obedience itself
defines the permeable frames of our
religious experience
one way to summarize this is to say that
religious believers in america have
become less orthodox
not that there are fewer self-identified
religious adherents but that the
religions themselves have become less
invested in questions of heresy and
dogma
for example
surveys over the last 50 years have
documented the diminishment in certain
forms of retributive deities
three quarters 75 percent of adolescents
in 1961 believe that god punished people
who sin
this statistic fell by 1975 to slightly
more than half
and today the numbers of americans who
believe god is a punishing agent active
in their existence is statistically
negligible
what i want to point to today is how
certain forms of divine ecclesiastical
and religious authority have diminished
while parental work and responsibility
seemed to have increased
there has been a persistent relationship
between religious ideation and parental
religious practice in the 20th century
one sociologist did a massive study of
this uh in the mid-1990s
and he found that 75 of protestants left
their churches during late adolescence
sort of pubescent rebellion against
their father churches but then he
remarked
having children
is the number one impetus people then
have for returning or coming back to
their church or synagogue 49 of those
same surveyed returned to church in
their late 30s in response to having had
children
a 2007 survey by parents magazine agreed
finding that 64 percent of parents
interviewed claim that they were more
religious spiritual since becoming a
parent
these examples offer a kind of
suggestive sociology of american
parenting and its spiritual connotations
the sense of a need for something else
to be there as i do this thing so
concentrated
in the remaining space of this talk i'm
going to consider connections between
the religious history of the united
states and its cultural ideologies of
parenting
and as i do this i'm not going to refer
a lot to the way that um sectarian
groups prescribe very particular
parenting strategies for example like
the latter-day saint recommendation of a
family home evening or the hindu
practice of talking about vedic precepts
during everyday life
instead what i want to do is consider
the way parenting is figuring centrally
and discussions of american life
especially as americans struggle with
the questions of what kind of individual
will be the most successful in changing
religious imperatives and market
concerns
parenting concerns all the biggest
issues of existence
otherness community freedom
responsibility critique interpretation
love
what i want to track is how we came to
embrace parenting
as one of the richest discursive spaces
for the consideration of these questions
in public
i will move through an account of the
history of parenting at a clip
previously unseen
that gathers its conceits into
interpretive clusters
including we're going to hustle people
and we're going to go from colonial
republican hygienic industrial and
service rapidly moving to the present in
an effort to try to provide summary
descriptions from various literatures
educational moral scientific
creating uh they slip into a kind of um
fantasy ascription
what can we really know from such a
fantasy script from a kind of
description of the ideal parent what we
know is something very spectral
i i'm mindful as a historian what can we
know from a manual of existence pretty
much nothing to the actuality of
existence yet i think we can know quite
a great deal about the spectral concept
of the terms of my adjudication
notably absent
yet present in a way that we will see
is the rich material and consequential
racial history of parenting a history
that would necessarily include the
invocation of native american relocation
slave families immigrants and refugees
as well as the specific analyses of
differential access to the very
institutional and governmental resources
i will be highlighting as supporting
these sort of icons and ideologies
this is a story that does not tell those
stories this is as typical in the
beginning of a plot this is a story that
focuses on a bourgeois mentality that i
make iconic of the story that plots us
from catherine beecher to miss ann
romney and g stanley hall to mr dr james
dobson
this is a broad genealogy of a
collective largely white will about
parenting in america
if the absence of parents define the
beginning of american history
parental presence defined in various
ways american success
and the moral consequences of that
success from the 18th century to the
21st
and now we
begin in the 17th and 18th century
america etiquette manuals and moral
treatises constantly seem to define and
liken the relationship between parents
and children in hierarchical terms quite
reminiscent of the colonial relationship
here are two quotations
1712 benjamin wadsworth writes children
should patiently wear and grow better by
the needful chastisements and
corrections their parents give them
a 1768 treatise said
to children
grumble not nor be discontented at
anything thy parents appoint speak or do
parents had one job
to break the will of their children so
they would become adults who would
sacrifice their personal desires for the
good of the larger circles of authority
they occupied including those of family
church king and country
british colonists did not interpret
individualism or ambition as positive
aspects of a child's disposition to be
fostered
rather they believe the children were
innately sinful and required the
controlling authority of a parent to
teach them self-discipline
a revolution in parenting transpired
simultaneously with the american
revolution
in the early national period our
contemporary conceptions of child
nurture began to take shape as john
demos wrote significantly about and
children were increasingly understood to
be less sinful
indeed children began to be enchanted by
a parental dynamic bent upon pressing
the family into political significance
catherine beecher one of the foremost
theorists of 19th century domesticity
female and otherwise dedicated her 1869
volume the american woman's home two
this is her language the women of
america
in whose hands rest the real destinies
of the republic
mothers directed republican parenting as
fathers guided republican economic
independence each one relied on the
other for its perpetuation
despite this clarity about the natal
importance of the american home the
available child-rearing manuals offered
a set of very conflicting demands to
parents a pattern to be continued
parents were told teach your children to
submit to a christian conscience at the
same time circulating cultural images
emphasize the importance of free market
savvy and as one of them said a fierce
will for american success
from the standpoint of religious history
this contradictory endorsement of
individual independence and christian
obedience can be seen across the
american landscape as schismatic sex
formed by the month and
non-denominational evangelical
benevolent societies increased in number
and size
a new circulating interdenominational
concept of national christianity became
a form of authoritarian speech that
inspired everything from the new
enshrinement of the mother as a societal
arbiter
to the abolitionist arguments focused on
the terrifying domestic familial
displacements of enslavement
such a presumptively christian
configuration for family life was not
met with universal acclaim
many if not all 19th century
communitarian critiques of existent
religious authority like those supplied
by the latter-day saints the rapides the
united perfectionists all included
centrally indictments of this nuclear
family and its norms for sexual practice
and gender identity
across the country individuals resisted
this new protestant american rectitude
in favor of experimenting with very
relatively new prescriptions about right
parents families marriages
whatever parental authority that
christian observers prescribed to quell
indulgent sensibilities there was also
an equal cultural tug
to encourage rebellion and that
marvelously republican child as seen in
the multiple depictions of the impish
child polling pranks on mom dad
servants what not
and the confused results were deemed to
be thoroughly american
from one european observer
parents love their children as dearly
and intensely as europe but exercise
less control less authority
american parents are far more forbearing
they meeker with their children than
they are in europe
the invention of this republican
nurturing parent had not it seemed
produced a child willing to be
controlled
if republican parenting sought to
instantiate a right citizen
lively wakeful angry ready hygienic
parenting sought to construct the
developmental apex of civilization
children ought to receive the very best
that science had to offer and they ought
to to embody physically and morally the
very best human kind humankind can be
in practice these two forces moral and
scientific were much more overlapping
than oppositional
for example in the book the christian
family psychologist george
walker fist
argued for a child-centered home that
was run by his language constructive
discipline
this home would include a regular family
council as well as regular times for
prayer worship instruction
when he was trying to reach though for a
metaphor to describe this ideal familial
community fisk wrote that the home was
his language a laboratory a place where
children could daily observe different
practices of religion and learn the
right ones through godly parenting
the home became a scientific laboratory
due in part to the permeating effect of
the child study movement
led by american psychologist g stanley
hall the child study movement sought to
enlist large numbers of ordinary
citizens in a broad effort to deepen
both public and scientific understanding
of human development
the child study movement offered
critical data for the advocacies of the
social purity and the social hygiene
movements
which connected concepts of moral virtue
to physical practices
these movements included the
distribution of bathing manuals to new
immigrant communities political
arguments on behalf of birth control
campaigns to outlaw prostitution and
eugenics propositions
during the turn from the 19th to the
20th centuries scientists became more
engaged in the public sphere in the wake
of world war 1 scientific evidence
became the critical component of any
federal legislative action
moral hygiene laws against a christian
moralism still at work in american
jurisprudence offering new sociological
and medical data as a kind of social
perfectionism that might resolve the
bodies of all those unwashed masses
coming to shore this is when we can see
a sciencia parentis becoming thoroughly
identifiable a rash of new child rearing
manuals began to appear in the united
states in the 1920s as one prominent
historian of the american family has
argued the 20th century described as the
century of the child became their
language a century of anxiety about the
child and the parent's own anxiety
the number of agencies and manuals
devoted to children and their proper
care increased exponentially
as the author of religious education of
the family described
today's parents
are becoming more and more interested in
the rational performance of high duties
and formed and they're forming
associations in church christian
associations women's clubs and
institutes are studying the subject
there is a general desire for guidance
this organizational development
surrounding the subject of parenting
reflected the expanding national culture
of education the incursion of
therapeutic idiom in all of public life
and the formation of federal agencies to
nurture and monitor human welfare
hygienic parenting was a very potent
discourse one that identified the child
as a primitive subject to be developed
into a civilized adulthood in a process
of recapitulation evocative of the very
worst excesses of social darwinism
yet these arguments would not persist in
precisely that form the scientism became
an excess and a rebuttal of marriage
that happens in every transition
in my plot as historian martha
wolfenstein has spoken about the
transition in the 1920s and 1930s was
that there was a transformation in the
conception of the child that was a
rebuttal against this kind of endless
measuring and monitoring of the child's
particularity this is her language where
formerly the mother was to exercise a
ceaseless vigilance removing the thumb
from the child's mouth as often as he
put it in
now she is told wolfenstein explained
not to make a fuss
to let the child act without
interruption
if hygienic parent would require the
persistent correction and moral devotion
to the facil the physical development of
your child the new iteration of
parenting recommended offered a kind of
mandate that the parent not merely
raised their child carefully
particularly with great detail
but also that the parent take pleasure
in their child naughty or nice
parenting became and this is
wolfenstein's locution a practice of fun
morality the test of your parenting was
no longer your child but whether you
lived a life devoted to the fabulous
enjoyment of your child
if republican parenting emphasized the
creation of able citizens and hygienic
parenting molded civilized subjects
industrial parents focused their energy
on creating a massive population of
capitalist consumers who could outnumber
outspend any cold war enemy
the industrial parent used the
exponentially increasing array of
consumer packaged goods to tend every
part of a child's physicality and
intellectual development
they were handmaidens of the
military-industrial complex transferring
the post-war productivity to a very
intimate home front
following world war ii it seemed that
everything in the american landscape
existed to foster children and their
parents
tracked homes automobiles highway
infrastructure in-home furnishings
public schools industry worked overtime
to supply the material context for the
materialization of this the definitive
baby boom
countless incentives from federally
financed mortgages to tax deductions
supported the establishment of nuclear
families with children
the birth rate rose among all social
occupational economic and ethnic groups
and a remarkable consensus of
reproductive behavior
communities like levittown pennsylvania
earned the nicknames fertility valley
and the rabbit hutch to describe their
natal excess although the baby boom was
fueled in part by the post-war economic
boom it also resulted in a profound
change in the national political culture
parenthood now became an absorbing
creative profession a career second to
none wrote one writer in 1946
this is a very single transition in my
historical account as it is when
exterior authorities moral and hygienic
become internalized by the parents
when dr spock remarked trust yourself
you know more than you think you do he
effectively concluded the era of
hygienic parenting turning from outside
scientific authorities toward the
analysis of their own maternal and
paternal feelings
this did not however diminish the role
of parenting manuals or their authors
rather it's going to elaborate the role
of the author as an interpretive guide
to those unexplored parental feelings
as families lived an increasingly
atomized physical settings
child emanuel met authors became virtual
village elders boon companions and
confessors to those who bought their
texts and considered the application of
their complex recommendations
to me this is a very significant
transition in the history of self and
other
the parenting gurus spock or otherwise
existed mainly to help the parent to
help themselves to see what it is the
child wanted most to be and to do
the purpose of parenting was to come to
understand your child as they were not
to compel them to formal rules or
abstract metrics
for 52 years sales of dr benjamin
spock's baby and child care
were second only to the bible in the
united states
this engagement with a child
was spock argued the absolute highest
calling
him
taking care of their children seeing
them grow and develop into fine people
gives most parents despite the hard work
their greatest satisfaction in life
it is a creative and generative act on
every level
pride in other worldly accomplishments
usually pales in comparison
in the world of dr spock there is no
such thing as a willful child there is
only a misunderstood child
his handbook included short
recommendations
usually only two to three paragraphs in
length about every conceivable child
care question
posed often and some of you probably
know this as a series of questions to
the parent
this passage i'm about to show you a
passage i'm like building up to a reveal
um if you haven't seen it you're just in
for a treat today so
every as you read this passage keep in
mind that to me what's interesting about
it is um it's sort of a hum that the
text has a kind of hum that i would i
would myself want to very much like into
meditative transitions but we'll hold
that back for the q a for right now
notice the responsibilities of the
parent
the kind of interactions that are made
ideal between parent and child the
critical role material goods play in the
management of a child's disposition
and the question who is the boss
frequent tantrums are most often due to
the fact that parents haven't learned
the knack of handling this behavior
tactfully
if your child is having frequent temper
tablets ask yourself the following
questions does she have plenty of chance
to play freely outdoors
are there things for her to push and
pull and climb on there
indoors has she enough toys and
household objects to play with and is
the house child-proofed do you without
realizing it arouse bulkiness by telling
you to come and get her shirt on instead
of slipping it on without comment or
asking her if she wants to go to the
bathroom instead of leading her there or
bringing the potty to her when you have
to interrupt her to play to get her
indoors or meals do you frustrate her
directly or get her mind on something
pleasant
when you see a storm brewing do you meet
it head-on grimly or do you distract her
to something else
time and again spock's ideas were
described repsonically with enormous
relief
as common sense
and they quickly pervaded the landscape
parents referred to their children as
spock babies with pride
a poll of more than a thousand new
mothers found that 64 of them had read
baby and child care 30 years after the
book was released of this group four of
every five referred to the book at least
twice a month
doctors and insurance agents gave it
away for free well into the 70s with
every birth
dr spock becomes a national potter
familias whose wisdom emanates from a
kind of set of commandments
he argued that parents could achieve
enlightenment through the admirable
patience and quiet labor of submissive
parenting
spock was the ideal mouthpiece for
industrial parenting his parent was the
assembly line laborer possessing a stoic
constancy before a job described as
necessary necessarily hard but
constantly revelatory
not everybody affirmed spock's view
conservative columnist stuart alsup
complained that an entire generation was
sparked when they should have been
spanked
later evangelical psychologist james
dobson would author his book titled dare
to discipline as a counter measure to
the leniency he identified in spock
debate about parental authority
was a debate in part about what
political arrangement the practitioner
preferred
during the late 20th century
conservative political leaders
increasingly aligned themselves with
conservative religious leaders
developing an argument about family life
and family values that was they claimed
a metanamim for right governance
meanwhile an expanding parade of child
care gurus would offer nurturing
descriptions of children for working
mothers and fathers trying to cultivate
right relations with their child as they
also sought to survive the changing
market world the industrial parent had
produced a generation of children
appropriate
to the increasingly consumer republic
and a generation of children disaffected
from any other authority other than
their own
the late 20th century parent
was is
we'll talk about that in the q a and
service to the child managing and
strategizing every aspect of their
person to maximize their market
potential
during the 1990s several critical
economic and demographic shifts took
place that would affect the practice of
parenting including the rampant
expansion of american higher education
the outsourcing of industry and the
corresponding transition to an
information economy
and profound reapportionments of gender
demographics in all occupations
with an increase in standards of living
and educational access american children
live lives a profound material plenty
when compared to their historical
predecessors
this improvement in children's lives led
to an escalation of the minimal standard
for a child's well-being
meanwhile the ubiquity of mass
entertainment brought new anxieties
about cultural experience and mental
development and the decline in child
labor raised questions about the
function and identity of children
depending on your vantage and this is a
quote uh two quotes
contemporary american kids may represent
the most indulged people in the history
of the world or they may be understood
as the most pressured young people in
the history of the world
certainly parents have been figured as
responsible for the results of this
excess and as one child psychologist
commented never before have parents been
so convinced that their every move has a
ripple effect into their child's future
success
concomitant to these ships in children's
culture
were significant alterations in
religious life
more and more americans identified
themselves as spiritual not religious
an incantation that included both those
free-thinking participants in the new
age movement and
attendance at non-denominational
christian services
what unite a very diverse spectrum of
believers is the disavowal of
denomination
for more and more americans being
religious meant something disconnected
from institutions and authorities
the practice of religion is now a looser
concept comprised of reading groups
therapeutic practices and a combinatory
of sectarian ideas
a 1995 article for example in parents
magazine outlined the spiritual values
parents a relatively secular outfit
spiritual values that every parent
should insert into family activities
here's the list select the congregation
that matches your family's needs and
personality
set aside sometime every week for sacred
family time teach kids tolerance
introduce your children to different
faiths by taking them to interfaith
services or activities in your community
answer big questions directly
and finally when children ask about good
and evil birth or death don't reply with
a complicated theological response
these values did not belong to any
single creed they seem to be presented
as the generally agreed upon moral
middle of a presumptively plural society
and so as the terms of parental success
were increasingly narrowed to
educational ascendance the terms of
religious articulation became
purposefully vaguer determined by the
needs of the believer and the needs of
the whole family
another article in another parenting
magazine described that the most
successful churches and synagogues
envision their congregations not as a
center for theological debate or
discussion or as a center for ritual
practice but as the language a hub for a
network of families
churches will not succeed if they focus
on theology or doctrine they succeed if
they provide activities that meet the
needs of young families and not this
article concludes the other way around
within this culture of religious
fluidity and parental ambition a very
strange subject of parenting took center
stage very briefly in the mid to late
90s
since the 1970s the divide between
parent-centered practice and
child-centered practice was increasingly
determined by a presumptive religious
identity
child-centered proselytizer like barry
bravelton and penelope leach were
avowedly secular advocates of parental
practices of listening loving learning
interacting
whereas the self-proclaimed
judeo-christian experts such as james
dobson william damon loudly condemned
what they saw as the decadent state of
american culture arguing for a
disciplining parent in an era of service
parenting
this dichotomy achieved notoriety in the
1990s when the corporal punishment of
children became a topic of heated social
and political debate
a massive scholarly effort replied to
data that suggested conservative
protestants were more likely than other
parents to value obedience from their
children and use corporal punishment to
do so spanking in particular became a
public object
a state of emergency took place in reply
as scholars scrambled to assemble
evidence from research on the physical
discipline of children to prove that
corporal punishment was ineffective at
deterring child misbehavior that
children subjected to corporal
punishment tended to be more aggressive
with peers than children who experienced
alternative forms of discipline
what to me is very peculiar about this
blip of reactive social science is
twofold
first the available empirical evidence
did not suggest that christian parents
did in fact use corporal punishment only
that some of their child care manuals
recommended that a light tap on the
bottom could get what you wanted
second and more importantly the broader
demography of american religion
largely turning as it was away from such
modes
made coverage of this kind of marginal
biblical readings very disproportionate
to the sociological real
yet if early 20th century social
scientists sought to combine moral
programming
with scientific recommendation
late 20th century social scientists
seemed bent upon exiling all forms of
religion from cultural practice as if
religion was the last false authority
left to the liberation of the happy and
healthy parent
but the parent can't be so easily freed
and the problem of parenting didn't go
away if corporal punishment was itself
largely as it was in the public sphere
it reviled
perhaps this reaction to marginal
protestant parental practice was a red
herring
in the late 1990s parents and experts
struggled with much bigger dramas as
there were an increased incidence of
violence enacted by children and
teenagers
talk of spanking protestants may have
been a kind of convenient sacrificial
object for a public lacking answers
about the expansion in youth
pharmacology the increase in school
shootings juvenile depression and
diagnosis of add and adhd
if religion could just be the culprit
then the cure could be simple less
religion more parenting
if religion wasn't the only problem then
giving all the existing literature on
child nurture
for all of those problems adhd violence
parents had only themselves to blame
looking back from this era of service
parenting to those that preceded it
it's possible to make several now broad
claims about the relationship between
religion and american parenting
at the same time that there has been i
argue a diminishment in creedal
orthodoxies
the expectations of what it means to be
a parent have become more orthodox
not that parents are more religious but
that more people are treating parenting
religiously
relatedly there are more areas of
imagined perfection within the frame of
child development
of course no parent can claim to be
comprehensive or ideal in their
parenting but all parents would speak
now of parenting as an occupational
force in their lives
being a parent today isn't just a
component of existence but an ordering
fact of it one which seems to press at
the limits of sanity wellness time
budget ability
parenting has become the determinative
calling for late modern adults
examples from the disputes often
electoral of summer 2012 illustrate the
contradictory positions held within this
new landscape of nurturance
during that time it was difficult to
avoid the subject of parenting
largely exhibited through the
complicated and fraught figure of the
mother
here too two quotations from both of the
candidates wives speaking about the
centrality of their motherhood is their
capacity to lead
in the early 20th century the elements
of infant nurture have gone decidedly
public
including entire economies psychologies
and lobbies dividing the world between
good and bad parents depending on the
practices that they pursue
amid the din of debate though about
toddler breastfeeding and super mothers
about nannies and quality time about the
new slacker dads and the old midwifery
i am trying to nominate all of these
topics as topics for the study of
religion because to me there's one hum
of truth in all of these subjects
that practicing parenting is central to
the american moral life determinative of
the american moral imagination
in the mid 1990s parents magazine
surveyed more than 7 700 readers and
found that there was a universal
agreement that teaching children was the
practical way to make a lasting
contribution to society
elaine tyler made a historian who's
written quite a bit on childlessness
worries about this she writes many
americans believe that the only place
they can find true happiness is in
private life
this belief praises an overwhelming
burden as well as an overwhelming sense
of experience expectation
on individual procreative behavior as
determinative of the moral life
in a moment which the public sphere
seems unwieldy and may be undisciplined
being a parent seems perhaps the only
way to change the world
a religious history of american
parenting shows that there has not been
a secularization of the american family
in which religion has increasingly
absented itself
instead this history shows that
parenting provides a mode of religious
expression
if religious orthodoxy is understood as
a submission of individuals to a
comprehensive theological system
parental orthodoxy could be conceived as
a submission of individuals to the work
of parenting as determining the lives of
its practitioners
the home i argue has not become merely a
replacement for the church it has become
the genesis of the secular that defines
our religious world
scholarship that tries to tackle the
embodied material and social facts of
this dynamic
would offer not only portraits of the
history of the family
but also i think key exhibits in the
history of religions
thank you so much
i would be yes hi hi
um really enjoyed the talk especially
the
conclusion
um one thing that i
i'm not sure the analogy extends
perfectly and you can probably convince
me otherwise his religion has been
forever embodied as a community right
yes and i don't talk to my neighbor
right on you know we don't meet weekly
to discuss how i'm going to raise my
kids so yes is that completely gone or
am i not thinking of it no that's a
great question so i mean this project
for me very much came out of i wrote
this book about oprah winfrey where um
many people look at oprah and just say
well that's just narcissism that can't
be religion because it's self-help and
the new age and so oprah's famous for
propounding all these spiritual
observers who guide her and only her
through her problems and through
watching her you learn how to take care
of yourself
and as i was watching the show and
talking about it in its relationship to
religious history the thing that also
worried me or concerned me was precisely
this absence of community sometimes
oprah show would create book clubs
around it sometimes it would lead to
women meet and watch the show but pretty
rarely it was largely individual
self-betterment and the question of
community seemed to be sort of hanging
spectrally over the entire 20th century
in the study of religion how do we solve
the problem precisely what you're saying
which is i don't talk to my neighbor
right in history of philosophy let's all
start weeping i don't talk to my
neighbor
you're right but we do talk obsessively
investedly with the question of these
children my spouse and partner the
practice of making this family i am
trying to argue i think is and this is
where the critique is suggested and not
finished increasingly the site of
devotion and the question of its
interconnectedness to a broader
community you're saying that might make
it more real religion and i would say
that might make it right religion but
i'm interested in talking about the
habitus of that family as the form of
community that we're now most conscious
of that's a very sharp thing to say and
there could be many replies of well i go
to this synagogue i do this kind of
activism we do this habitat for humanity
as baptists as family members but i'm
trying to say what's the primal social
unit of contemporary americans i would
argue it's not some concept of community
it's the family and so in that i am
trying to definitely take up the very
rough edge of that question you're
asking which is what's the consciousness
of community in that as i quoting ellie
and tyler may i'm trying to raise
is this good is this bad how do we feel
about that do we think that this is a
way of political as i think mae is
overtly saying this is the end of
politics it's it's the beginning of
something very worrisome or is she
totally wrong because as we see the kids
wives use it to interesting effect we
see both michelle obama and romney
lassoing their vocabulary of motherhood
to have political projects what do we
think of those um any event so that's
precisely the kind of object that i'm
trying to react to and think about and
so thank you yeah
absolutely and so one of the things i
like to
in the road there's really just
historians who could talk about this um
when you study history religions it's
not a lot of people like oh you're so
pious no you're so pious it's a lot of
you're not pious and you're less pious
so the history of religions is filled
with a kind of cruel observation of how
that person manages the eucharist
whether or not they're as enthusiastic
as they need to be how regularly do they
dobbin so there is a kind of cruel
estimation in the history of religions
too and i precisely want to get at um my
friend sent me these crazy blogs in new
york where they're posing questions they
just depicted this in the last 30 rock
where they show do you know the name of
those there's they're blocking you
basically go on i'm sorry urban baby and
you they're all these acronyms and
they're basically asking material
questions and then lead to these massive
debates but the reason why i love these
and this is going to be part of my media
ethnography with this project is they
really get to some intense issues it
starts with this sort of total banality
and grotesque materialism but it often
falls out to statements about self
another about family about right life
about good bad people you might be
disgusted by the values propounded but
i'm at least excited that values are
being debated that people are getting to
a point in some form of a public and
saying what would be the right way to
have a human being in the world what is
a human being in the world so
there's often we have i do have kind of
underbelly ah you know but there's also
an excitement that at least a debate
occur so yeah this question of social
media is that what kind of community is
social media per pound is a very rich
question yep
and i'm still going to be going over it
for a while in terms of all the issues
that it raised for me but i guess the
my one little sort of question i guess
is mythologically so part of how i
experienced this i had my kids over here
in parenting
yes as opposed to in scholarship or in
gendered performance but their dogma
appears yes
yes
freedom right
yeah and among other
things that
much of that dogma has i feel like the
sort of priests and philistines have
been out of others
and some of the places where it was and
so for example the question about
communities yeah i ended up finding like
mother groups terribly
right
themselves but then they were going
crazy and so they started doing all
these like scenes and stuff yes which is
dissenting yes
right to the dissenting forms yes yeah
so that's great and tomatoes there's a
couple different forms of descending
culture and i'll be efficient someone
takes some more questions but i love
that question i want to talk about it
because to me descent is often
articulated through two different worlds
one is uh the kind of one you just
described kind of hipster bite back
onion and there's a history of that in
america but the other form of dissent
which i'm obviously invested in religion
is revivals of other kinds of orthodoxy
so that's why you could see me kind of
being interested in james dobson here
not as
my colleague lou gravitous bailly has
written a lot about dobson and his role
and why he talks about parenting the way
he does and here's not the licensed
absent dobson is disturbing to read him
access is to travel the mind of a person
who truly hates human beings but
but he has taken on just like the
mormons did they take out the question
there's something very normatively
disturbing about all these mothers have
to enjoy parenting all the time you have
to enjoy every part of it first of all
it's exhausting second of all it's a
duty so then he runs to duty he says you
could not have to feel so bad about not
enjoying it all the time be treated like
a good christian duty i like that
alternative of a new vocabulary of
hermeneutic even though in the end i'm
not going to side with him
interpretively so yes i'm trying to find
sources for the set i welcome those
you're going to send me those links i
i'm collecting i'm in a collecting stage
so i love the spaces where people can
bite back against the normal
suppositions of sentimental joy which is
so often attributed to this plot yeah hi
uh well i was i was going to ask a very
theoretical question about your
definition of religion yeah in the
religious because i tend to get
uncomfortable when people define
religion very broadly yeah i think
you're true but i want to ask a much
more vanilla question now yeah what what
do you make of the
vehement and and sort of surprising to
me right-wing reaction to michelle
obama's initiatives with regard to
healthy eating and going outside i mean
these seem like very sort of common
sense yeah traditional american
kind of parenting things is there a
racial dynamic is there a class dynamic
we've got this liberal you know
this uh you know liberal educated black
woman telling us to eat kale and
everything right i think you're very
much on the plot line i would go on and
then i would just add that the
exteriority so i can and as my students
we will talk about michelle obama and my
classroom religion sexuality because
it's such a beautiful example of
foucault's description of biopower
because she's really trying to say a
healthy population looks this way and
feels this way and gives prescriptions
for it but the thing that's to me
incredibly admirable about the plot and
i think is therefore upsetting to chris
is it takes people so outside it takes
them into communities and mixes them
together the fear that these terrains
are unpoliced unpolice mixing is a huge
concern for most religious communities
what will happen if we are not being
more regulated using public spaces it
seems to one of the blogs i saw on this
point just in researching for my class
lecture was one that's just worried
about community gardens as socialist
spaces so one can imagine you know you
can get to it you your analysis is
already there i saw land really quickly
though he raised at the beginning this
question of the definition of religion
which for those who are not in the study
of religion do not know how many pages
hours lives have been lost on the wars
of defining religion and i did
absolutely the brother was right say i
did a very general which is something
about religion is concerning the
question of self and other and i do that
because so much time my one version is
taught open by saying i'm a person who
really loves paul tillich's definition
of religion where he talks about his
ultimate concern and i love sociological
definitions like durkheim's where he
gets hyperactive about what's an actual
community whether they have what objects
they have so i am fascinated by both
forms of study of religion one which
tries to get the things i feel deeply
about with large groups of people that's
religion and the other groups that are
trying to be more technical about it
this is the four elements you need
that's a religion and i tend to think in
contemporary american culture that the
technology of the second is going to
keep you out of studying much as
religious anymore we really do run into
because precisely the first question the
elements that you need to find a
religious life the kinds of numbers in
community that the people who define a
relationship to religion it's hard it's
hard to find those kind of classic
objects community creed code cultists so
i'm interested in trying to figure out
what spaces of religion exist now given
those kinds of changes
yeah the only the only reason i bring
that up is because like
i i tend to worry that sometimes talking
about religion in these more
sociological ways of you know concern
for the sacred community and values and
stuff can sort of confuse people when
you when you say that like oh religion
is still important in families when like
you know the the secularization
secularization hypothesis that you seem
you know right protecting in a sort of
literal sense of what most people think
of as religion you know seems to be true
right and my own position would be that
there's that in the history of religions
what people think about religion that
way is a very short history 1910 to like
1960. so when you're talking about
religion that way there's a very short
period of time where people thought
about religion and that way i'm a
lutheran very short window of history
and otherwise it's so much as historians
in the room could all speak about it's
about a way of life it's integrated into
daily practice or it's really
complicated and combinatory but this
story and the definition of religion
that was encapsulated by a particular
mode which all of us could have narrated
through social science in that time
period incorporating american
communities the exclusion of other
communities so anyway it's a great
question many classes taught some people
in this room don't find as exciting as
you and me but um but does anyone ask
any other questions you know last
question yes miss raven um so we just
talked about your definition of religion
and i would
enjoy some reflection on the other
categories that you used to talk because
you talk a lot about parenting parents
family um and obviously these are also
sort of
contested politicized terms and i'm also
just interested in their relationship
like the parent as an identity versus
the tacos called the practice of
parenting and the family as the habitus
so just some reflection on those
categories and their relationships yeah
which one would you like me to focus on
yeah so the word that when you come up
on the dictionary of parenting most
often the language of cultivation so it
has this kind of interesting as some of
you may know an agricultural history to
it the sort of way in which you are
going to cultivate and make new types of
things so to me why that got me
interested was
reading if you google or search in any
kind of archives for the category of
parent it doesn't show up as a
vocabulary term in prescriptive manuals
about what a mother or a father might do
until the 1920s so to me that's very
interesting that at the very moment that
it becomes more propounded as a science
a particular technology here's how you
make a good child doesn't appear in the
literature until the 20th century so
what are people doing before then
they're creating kinds of communities
they're trying to get you know literal
animal subjects into some civilized
reality so i'm trying to actually speak
about how the vocabulary of it changes
over time itself i am using a very
contemporary term parenting which have
been unrecognizable to somebody in 1870.
and that doesn't mean that they're
mothers or fathers it means that that is
an activism so i am trying to take that
word and say parenting a word we all use
very naturally as a description for our
habitus is something relatively new and
attached to this plotline of the history
of religions i'm trying to describe
another
additional question and another way of
asking what i said for is why why
are you focusing on parenting and not
the family or parents right because to
me the the activism is in the doing of
it that that's what it should be an
absorbing practice that there's no part
of your life that would not be marked
out this project began for me when i was
with a friend um from college a
philosophy major in college who gave me
a 40-minute monologue about those nooks
those things that you put into the mouth
of babies they say and uk i think that's
the brand name they're just little you
know there's a little sucker i mean but
like
pacifier that's the word thank you um we
call him the nook in my world but like
and so she had 40 minutes about whether
or not to win and whether to remove the
nook
and that was one of the most elaborate
descriptions of this person who'd spoken
largely in abstractions for much and now
all of a sudden this practice was the
source of all cognizance but to me
that's parenting therefore is a practice
an epistemology and trying to get at
that is that that conjunction is is to
me that the labor of the project yeah
yeah sorry i would also ask too in
parenting are you also talking about the
part of the society that is not
necessarily a parent
i'm wondering
that one of the things i'm trying is
where does moral life come from absent a
parenting practice i would ask i would
just reflect that back to all of us
um
yeah one more question from the
um audience you very much i have a very
uh tiny statistical question
you talked about um in your more general
remarks at the beginning
the uh rebellion of the adolescent away
from the religious institutions
they them the parents stop going as
often yes so that's that this is this
guy uh who's devoted his life to start
family life cycles and churches and once
their kids hit adolescence and they met
most of them abandoned they then fade in
adherence um this is a huge life cycle
study done out of georgetown and it
seems to be pretty consistent especially
if it focuses on protestant catholic
families but there's no analogous one
going on brandeis right now but when
they catch in
uh and jewish families which i said
she's not done with the study yet so i
don't know
the study was it was first initial 1997
another set in 2002.
so i'm going to take advantage of being
the host here and ask the last question
uh
i'm going to start off with an
observation i just want your reaction
and that my impression is looking at
the way
my family operated
and i got to observe it myself as the
child but also more importantly i had
two younger brothers over a decade
younger than i was so i got to see all
my parents interacting with them uh my
impression is that the way our family
worked and the way my parents parented
is very similar to the way our daughter
is parenting 70 years later right
whereas the striking thing that you said
that i didn't realize was that the
people in the united states i guess they
were teenagers had uh no longer believed
that god punished them for their sins
now that is a huge huge change where in
comparison to what i'd say were subtle
differences in parenting in my
experience right right or a cycle of
parenting where they're sort of you know
one generation does one thing another
one and then one repels by going to a
more you're saying they both changed a
lot my impression is the parenting has
probably changed a lot less than
religious beliefs oh that's interesting
that's interesting to think about that's
not what i have found that parenting has
changed a lot but i do interest i
mentioned that cycle of
obedience disobedience of being
disobedient yeah
well we'll see okay well that was a lot
of fun let me uh thank katie
number two
thank all of you for coming and asking
so many excellent questions
number three i'd like to extend two
invitations one to come to our reception
which is next door
in the common room and the second
invitation is to come back on april 2nd
for something completely different
paul tipton who's the new chair of our
physics department is going to talk
about whether the taxpayers of the world
got their money's worth in paying for
the discovery of the higgs boson
it ought to be a really interesting
discussion with both scientific and and
sociological questions that he's raising
so i invite you to come back then thank
you